Speaker 1: . All right, so I alluded to this
earlier.
You have to see the level of chaos that the
Mark Meadows Trump riot texts are causing
in right wing media.
So let me reset the story for you first and
then we're going to just jump into something.
I it's it's genuinely delightful.
I don't know how else to describe it.
Speaker 2: Earlier this week, Republican
Speaker 1: Congresswoman Liz Cheney, member
of the House Committee investigating the Jan.
six riots, read a bunch of text messages reportedly
sent from Fox News hosts and Donald Trump
Jr. to Trump's then chief of staff, Mark Meadows.
Speaker 2: And despite going on air that day
and for weeks downplaying
Speaker 1: the
Speaker 2: riots, it might have
Speaker 1: been antifa.
It was BLM.
It wasn't real Trump supporters.
I didn't actually see any Trump supporter
being violent as well as Trump's own son and
all of these Fox News hosts doing that.
On that day, they knew it was
Speaker 2: terrible, and they knew it was
Speaker 1: Trump's problem, and they were
trying to get Trump on TV to make a statement.
Tell him to send everybody home.
It exposes that everything they did after
the fact was just dishonest clean up, and
they knew exactly who was there that day and
that it was very bad
Speaker 2: for Donald Donald Trump,
Speaker 1: period.
They knew it.
They lied on
Speaker 2: TV to help Trump.
Speaker 1: No surprise it's been confirmed.
Now, all of the different factions are starting
to go at each other because they don't know
how to manage this last night.
Sean Hannity, one of the people implicated
in this entire fiasco, had a segment where
he invited on heraldo Rivera
Speaker 2: and this total right wing
Speaker 1: nut Dan Bongino, who just defends
Trump always and forever.
There's no situation where Bongino won't defend
Trump and Geraldo, even
Speaker 2: though he was a Trump
Speaker 1: supporter, is a friend of Trump.
Whatever Geraldo actually stands up sort of
for what's
Speaker 2: right and says to Hannity.
Listen.
Speaker 1: Because Hannity is continuing to
downplay the riots, he says this was a riot.
It was inspired by Trump supporters, period,
and Hannity tries to interrupt and her also
says, Wait a second, Sean.
Think back to when you sent those texts.
Think back to your frame of mind when you
realized these are Trumpists doing this and
this is violent and this is terrible.
And you texted Mark Meadows.
Think back to that, and Bongiorno just loses
it on her.
Although check this out
Speaker 4: was the obvious difference between
the riot that happened on January 6th and
the 500 odd that you correctly cite is concerning
and and damaging to America, to our psyche,
to our our physical well-being is that this
was a riot that was unleashed, incited and
inspired by the president of the United States,
which targeted for the purpose of American
democracy.
It didn't say no you that target the president's
speech.
Let me let me now stop.
The president said peacefully patriotically
marched to the Capitol.
That's your opinion.
I don't even want to go down that road.
That's not the question tonight.
The question is this corrupt committee.
The question is why this riot and not five
hundred and seventy four other rights?
The question is, is there any privacy in this
country anymore?
Or do they get to release thousands more of
individual private citizens tax?
I beg you, Sean, to remember the frame of
mind you were in when you wrote that text
on January 6th and when Laura did it, when
Brian did, and when Don Junior did remember
the concern you had?
Remember the the frustration?
And our beloved forty fifth president because
he called it a riot to be doing this.
Why doesn't he say something?
Why?
And he knew what the point is he did.
You saw unfolding before you.
He saw unfolding before your very eyes.
An attack on democracy.
Given that the check on the Constitution and
he did not call for that state, he said peacefully.
And then he did do it, Dan.
You have less than a minute or running out
of time here, although we've been arguing
about this forever.
The back stabbing of the president you're
engaging in is really disgusting, and it's
really vile that you pretend to be this guy
really resenting you to.
I resent that.
I supported Donald Trump on tape.
I supported Donald Trump until he abandoned
Let me democracy, let me be.
He abandoned the election results, and he
refused to peacefully refuse to accept the
will of the American people.
You heard it.
Nobody can hear you heard of it.
Leave it there and you stabbed him in the
back.
You heard.
Thank you.
Speaker 2: Thank you both.
Speaker 1: So it's not backstabbing.
It's telling the truth.
Geraldo is saying nothing controversial.
It was the Trumpist riot.
Sean Hannity knew
Speaker 2: it and texted
Speaker 1: Mark Meadows at the time to try
to stop it.
And now he's playing a completely different
version of events on TV day in and day out.
That's really it.
Like, there's no more story.
And Hannity pulls in Bongino to run interference,
and they're starting to just go after each
other.
Geraldo is no sage.
Right?
When heraldo is the voice of reason.
You know, things have gotten a little bit
wacky, but this is what
Speaker 2: you want to see.
Speaker 1: This committee has already done
so much good in all that it is
Speaker 2: exposed and all
Speaker 1: these people are more than willing
to go after each other to save themselves.
Remember that if Republicans had just gone
along with the original committee?
It is far less likely that all of this same
damaging information would have come out.
Why do I say that?
Well, the original comedy idea was, I believe
these are the right numbers.
Five Democrats, five Republicans.
When they would send
Speaker 2: out subpoenas,
Speaker 1: the subpoenas would have to be
signed off on not only by the Democratic chair
of the
Speaker 2: committee, but by the
Speaker 1: Republican vice chair of the committee.
Speaker 2: It was going to be truly
Speaker 1: a
Speaker 2: committee that was not just
Speaker 1: going to have carte blanche to
go fishing wherever they want Republicans.
And I'm not saying that that's what it is
now.
Speaker 2: But Republicans said, we're not
going to participate.
Speaker 1: We're protesting this entire thing
unless we're also looking into, you know,
the shooting of Steve Scalise four years ago
or whatever else.
We don't want to participate.
So Nancy Pelosi found some Republicans willing
to be on it, Liz Cheney on it, Adam Kinzinger
is on.
I don't remember if there's any other Republicans,
but at least the two of them.
And now you have a situation in which they,
by virtue of Republicans saying, we're basically
opting out of this thing and at least at the
party level, we don't support it, even if
you found a couple of our people to be on
this committee.
Now they are actually doing really good work
and exposing incredible things.
There was a PowerPoint for the coup.
Speaker 2: All these people who for months
Speaker 1: have been doing media
Speaker 2: saying it wasn't what it was on
that day knew
Speaker 1: exactly what it was.
And we're texting Mark
Speaker 2: Meadows and saying, please help
to
Speaker 1: stop it.
So it's excellent that the committee is doing
this.
It's exactly the type of inciting infighting
and bedlam that we want to see within the
Republican Party.
Bongino.
Hannity.
Geraldo, you have a war fighting.
That's exactly what we want.
They will turn on each other to protect themselves.
That's abundantly clear.
If you say, Hey, the riot was inspired by
Trump, which obviously it was, they accuse
their
Speaker 2: own of backstabbing
Speaker 1: and heraldo is or was a trumpet.
I mean, he makes it clear even in that segment.
The difference
Speaker 2: is that Hannity
Speaker 1: and Bongino
Speaker 2: will never admit that Trump did
Speaker 1: anything wrong.
Geraldo will admit it, and he'll still say
he is or was my friend
Speaker 2: and I did, or to support him.
It takes nearly 80
Speaker 1: year old Geraldo Rivera to apparently
realize that what took place on January 6th
was not just Partizan bickering
Speaker 2: or a rally.
It was
Speaker 1: something much darker and much
more sinister, and
Speaker 2: hopefully this level of
Speaker 1: chaos will continue